my friends and I we bought tickets to go
to Disneyland that's normal behavior and
and how many are there there are three
of us okay three grown adult women going
to Disneyland right and you know it's
California so I just assume you can take
marijuana everywhere wait I know that
marijuana is legal now but yeah but that
doesn't why would you assume you could
take it to Disneyland I just I just
thought oh it's cool famously and and
this is not any knock against Disneyland
but it's a famously button-down place
they really run a tight ship at
Disneyland you can take a carton of
cigarettes you can drink a California
adventure so I figured you can also just
get high so wait okay so this is what
you thought now tell the story so I had
a tin of chocolate marijuana chocolate
and I intervals yes edibles and I had it
in my bag and I didn't hide it so it was
like this tin that said marijuana
chocolate and then the guy opened it and
you gotta tell the story the guy you're
going through the gate so I'm going
through security and the guy opens my
back and it literally just falls out
it's I'm not marijuana chocolate on it
and these are the guys that are kind of
dressed like old-timey security guys
little white yapped ins hat yeah they're
dressed like steam steam ship captains
yeah so he looks at me and he's like you
can't bring that in and I look at him
and I'm like it's California he's like
no you can't bring in California
California yeah yeah seven knives fall
out you can't come in here with us hey
it's California these are my California
knives so he's like you have to dispose
of it so my friends and I go by the
trashcan and we're thinking we're not
gonna dispose this let's just put in a
ziplock bag and put it in our pocket and
we'll walk in and you know we just
didn't hide it right so wait so heat
they told you they don't you were
directed by these old man dressed as
steamboat captain's to go over and
dispose throw out yes your marijuana
your yeah well okay so we get to the
trash can and then we're putting it into
a ziploc bag and two other security
guards come up to us and they're like we
see what
doing oh my god and we were screaming we
weren't trying to hide it we're trying
to just put the weed in a ziplock so we
take it inside she's like no you can't
bring it into Disneyland right which I
thought was clear the first time why I
thought it was clear when they said
you've got to go dispose of that and
there's the trash can was that not clear
to you you know we also the guy who
looked at me like come on try to hide it
the guy who first checked my bag so I
was like oh this is an unlike a secret I
like obviously he's just saying like
hide it it's cool but he did not mean
that he meant get rid of it right and
I'm just gonna say this because I'm a
big fan of Disneyland and after Disney
Corporation and the products they make
when they say something I listen so
Disney if you're listening I want you to
know I'm listening and sona's not so
know what happened so then the lady
comes up to me the security guard and
another security guard we see what
you're doing you have to dispose of it
so I said okay and I just threw it away
and she says you can't throw it in the
trash kids will go in there and take it
and eat it
what yeah so I said I don't know what to
do with it and she's taking it as a
former Disney trash can
that's right true this is insane yes you
were and this isn't even a joke ladies
and gentlemen in podcast land yeah Matt
Gourley
worked at Disneyland and you were
dressed up as he was not dressed up in
trash can but were you that Lee operated
it oh I thought you were dressed up
trash can
I thought you think when it's much
better I thought that your job right
before meeting me was that they were
Zagan Yeah right like a year ago is that
they put a trash can on you and you had
to waddle around and go here comes that
coated lady this is why I keep feeling
the lset I want to be a lawyer but I
can't it's a trash can that dreams of
being a lawyer yeah is actually really
brilliant but because you keep throwing
marijuana
Hach he's too high and he can't pass the
LSAT I'm doing this is a story I just
created it guess what Disney if you
wanted it's yours
that's a great Pixar movie yeah so the
security card comes up - oh she says
listen either you disposed of it or your
day ends here for Mickey's sake please
what make the right this [ __ ] drives me
crazy I used to work there wait she said
for Mickey sake and I said whose sake
she goes Mickey's and I said Mouse
she said no Roark for Mickey Rourke's
sake because look what drugs did to his
career this is what they say every time
I go to Disneyland alike for Mickey
Rourke's sake but it sounds a lot anyway
she really said she's good for Mickey
seis to always say like have a Disney
day manager isn't everything it's gross
it's no I'm not talking on I'm not gonna
have anyone badmouth no it's a cult back
behind the walls yes you could tell she
did the way she was acting it's very
successful they make a lot of money and
I'd like to work for themselves alright
so she said for Mickey's sake and a nice
we know I was like Mouse and she goes
Mickey's sake and then I said did they
make you say that and she's she said no
I'm telling you for Mickey's sake you
need to figure out what to do here and I
literally first second stopped and
thought do I want to do Disneyland sober
and I almost left but we had paid like
$300 for these tickets so we we decided
to just get rid of them and we went in
but they missed a few mints that we had
in a ziplock bag so he still had a
really great day we we were high the
holding